looking out the peripheral vision over
here it's like studiously avoiding look
at ass yeah you don't that's too close
you think we're with each other look at
us no you guys are way too far away you
gotta you're gonna have to be a little
more bold he never watches this is not
even you're not gained gaining med oh
wait
nope might be coming around I think he's
coming closer it might spot you know
stop stop short oh here we go nope you
guys are just out of range look up look
up it's not not interested skies an
idiot oh here we go
sorry gents hate to be the bearer stupid
I bought new I was DTF tonight is he is
he broadcasting this oh look he sent
some friends to come watch you guys wait
there until the yeah we basically waited
get out of there I'm out here but I am
supercharged everything's cool over you
guys don't worry alright thanks for
watching us dance but head for nothing
blow this popsicle stand
it is a big [ __ ] jerk here trakis is
here drangus hey drunk up Patrick I'll
[ __ ] move head dry cap watch us back
dancing at all
oh they kind of hit me when I dumped my
god oh my god what does this key leo
guards is there - this is the best oh
he's awesome [ __ ] oh [ __ ] this is a riot
scene we need to like we need to move
there I'm super baby are we to get that
kill super it ignores they had first a
guard Oh No
I've made a better rapper name okay
Oh what's up I'm standing are throwing
anything oh you dog you dancing on his
throne I'll drag ah Danah died Oh dragon
don't go good alright an idiot sorry
I'll had to be done don't don't get
killed
why would I get killed he doesn't like
it when knowledge all the bad guys are
only trying to kill me now come dance on
his chair he really likes it all so
pretty here it was so Morris amigo God
there was a bad guy right there I really
did not anticipate that line very well
oh yeah oh yeah thank you very much
I got one that's all I could do okay you
I respawn good
oh yeah oh yeah oh there's a super
charts there just friggin tiny ass
flying robots to jerks drop on the
credit end around
before you buddy with the [ __ ] robots
go oh [ __ ]
thank you very much oh I got one of the
guards down
thank you that was very helpful
where's [ __ ] eat it rock up wants our
rock Oh
all right second killed gardez out yeah
get them with the rocket lunch uh we got
Big D me your little in this room oh
yeah good point
oh we're to [ __ ] race headshots all
day baby crit crit crit rack kind of
putting me down here yeah you're
definitely guts correct all his friends
have showed up
oh this is not good
all right this is don't worry I threw a
tiny knife at him this is the most fun
about playing this game this is actually
difficult Rob I'm coming for you buddy
thanks what's up that harpoons you know
testing all you can get oh yeah oh yeah
[ __ ] where's he at no God he's right
behind us
Rob see she's right down there okay come
revive me whoa oh my god
real I did not see him there Danny he's
running directly [ __ ] that apples are
you go dad we're both dead oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] do not die we're gonna die
move with serpentine motions and jumps
what are you straight to the right about
me you're dancing again you know I quit
Smash Hits off doing your float job oh
dammit your float jump is not a good oh
sorry that's alright
no you dude we were all dead it's just
cuz you're the last guy doesn't know how
to make it on you is he back up again
alright Big D
Doug's you have no place here begone
whoa you got close yeah he moves around
Koga his friends they are all about
yes guys are [ __ ] everywhere oh I got
ya
so this is a boss fight against the
street I'll show you this is like this
is like the boss fight and that Ouma
against our like we were kind of under
level for this so the boss fight yeah
that was a tough spot
back in 50 inches sellout are you dead
again phone no I'm dead
Rob isn't doing okay ten Oh
Bennett that that that that that that
that the death oh mama oh it's right he
is right on me daddy's back
number of IVs help me just get out of
there
hey big dork over here whoa found your
buddy
we've tracked it his attention
stuff is exploded it's coming in
oh yeah I saw okay hit by that we it
hurt us both you're bad in time right on
me rub scrub scrub
I'll bite I probably lost my super
enhance Oliver no I think you keep it
try to get in the yards up top here
first Eddie oh oh oh oh oh it was worth
it
ah man oh good the robots spawned it I'm
out
yeah a rose you can get me I'm gonna
destroy we're both in pretty good yeah
okay thank you I can again that way team
Oh robots they're so annoying
get out of my face I'm gonna go [ __ ]
like these guys split him up at least
yeah get up there alright alright I do a
super charge on this guy do if you can
do it on his lieutenants that would be
the most effective there up the left
side for sure I saw King how he is
definitely focused on me right now for
some reason so yeah what's up buddy your
your guns can't shoot over this thing
[ __ ] cows car are you kidding me guys
right on this side of the barrier from
the dude he's not hurting me alright
let's lay the firing on it you're always
just friends are out of here kill his
friends please well are they I don't
seem in the others if you have any
friends I don't think so I don't see any
more take them out yeah
well yeah if you put some put some heat
on this guy he seems to be you got it he
just does the same thing back to your
eyes I every time I what's in the back
vibing up there probably I mean intense
like that as well yeah I'm in ten
seconds just hanging there
oh don't worry about me I got your up
matter I mean she serves the [ __ ] big
guy
Oh
nice tough yeah I was gone
yeah yeah
anyone got pyro coming I just use mine I
use mine whoa try to get rub more funny
I guess we're hooking droids and [ __ ]
coming in the stairs hi I'm gonna get
those [ __ ] was running up there as
that
I got your damn nice gonna be anyone
near me he's down to work me
or you're gonna call man you can appear
he's down here near Ryan
drag watch your arses Oh
big boy
Big D you he's up top my throat my
throat oh I got work fine from grab a
throne yeah I said whoa
does he work or is he just doing daddy
works she a bunch of guys spawning off
the top again robots and some dregs
spawning a [ __ ] where you at I gotta
convey how much fun you got that one
song I can oh [ __ ] you're right by him
get in get in
oh damn it wow that was close oh my god
so close I was I was like that was half
a second yeah ridiculous
don't come near me I'm [ __ ] yeah he's
near
that's waiting to revive my eddo race
market you could possibly come grab me
oh I died in a cargo net
oh no we ran in a response a people's no
cuz you guys had not respawned as so you
were too you were still dead I just
didn't wait I just didn't stay alive
Lana yeah but we were out of respawn
countdown was gone
yeah it didn't it didn't say like three
oh really in five yeah and I'm neither
of us grains oh I didn't notice that oh
yeah yes it's respawning restricted
there's a time of it already but you can
come around I'm in a pretty safe place
[ __ ] yet spy girl behind the turn draws
attention Rob I don't [ __ ] over
yeah don't get mixing the fine line this
first wave is hard this first wave is
art all right we got this guy's yeah oh
my gosh you got it this time
stay frosty stay frosty winter ships
simek's fell alright alright we want to
take out all the little
Europe's first oops
face drag not having it
oh he's charging him I'm in no mood he's
in
these kills guards
that don't yeah I don't come through
dude that movie come on over here a
friend oh can we get it
Oh y'all can come get it yeah you
right behind you is where you are or is
where the bad guys don't that's what I
was I he's right about me don't worry
about it
put them up going up inside here yep go
get game you ready
oh sorry we couldn't do it
I jumped I thought I had you timed
perfectly and jumped away but then I got
to doing it I come for me maybe instead
of Danny or yeah he's back anyway
changeup a grenade
he's a way better one
the chart nice we got one of the guards
at least
guards am
that's it all right now I'm all for now
yeah now you can eye out on me
robot sit back
those [ __ ] commented like everywhere
we're just so honored that like [ __ ]
surrounded buddy yep right
or about them all charge Oh Oh God
hearts I'm gonna dead right by him but
if he pursues now he's coming there for
me go from it looks like he's heading
for me I don't these no damn you should
doc
charge I got a super charger ready to go
to roll away from watch how guys get out
he's right he's on the left
everybody send Drake oh yeah you turned
around so I could pop you in the grill
from maximum them and didn't you like it
you want it look at oh we got him
airflow this is walking okay he's just
Jesus Christ he goes at this as quick
there okay there's more [ __ ] coming
man I threw a tiny knife at him guys
don't worry they're each other
[ __ ] it out of there [ __ ] calling
from everywhere yeah they just
oh you've got to be kidding me what are
you gonna good good good good
he's on the left side Jen take your time
here to stay together and [ __ ] it make
sure you get rid of the mobs first yeah
no it's like tempting to go for it-- me
yep where's the boy hit the big guy
ah always right up by the throne oh now
he is there any mobs up there hello no
there's no one else up here just nearly
gone them boom almost right there
hey yeah gonna burn burn baby nice stuff
now we can sit in his throne yeah yeah
baby how'd you like that crib
brick come on Rob the doctor I guess ok
don't want her buddy oh I'll get on the
side yeah yeah that's the idea yeah
that's the side getting my dirty
footsteps although hey Rob get up here
and dance goddammit dance baby
oh yeah I like that dragon all right
choo-choo-choo whoooaaa
god damn that deserves it great eat some
of these quick deserves a great I'm good
to have my victory grape I won't have it
affect I regret to bring those grapes up
are these grapes mean seedless